AND THIS GUY,
WHAT'S YOUR STORY?
I SAW YOU AT THE THEATER
WHEN I WALKED BY
AT, LIKE,
WHAT TIME TODAY?
- UH, I THINK IT WAS,
LIKE, 2:00.
- THIS GUY GOT TO
THE THEATER AT 2:00.
I THOUGHT HE WAS
A REALLY BIG FAN,
TURNS OUT
HE'S [bleep] HOMELESS.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
- UH, I'M A LASER OPERATOR.
- A WHAT?
- A LASER OPERATOR.
- YOU MUST
GET TONS OF [bleep].
- JUST ONE.
[laughs]
- JUST ONE?
- YEAH.
- YOU HAVE A WIFE?
- UM, IN A COUPLE MONTHS.
- OH, YOU'RE GONNA--
YOU'RE ENGAGED?
- YES.
- WOW, WHAT DOES SHE DO?
- SHE--
- I KNOW SHE'S NOT A DENTIST.
YOU ASKED FOR THIS, BUDDY.
I DIDN'T--I DIDN'T--
- NO, HEY, HEY.
- COME HERE, LADIES.
LET'S CHECK YOU OUT
FOR A SECOND.
TWO FIVES
MAKE A TEN, RIGHT?
- RIGHT!
- [laughs]
- YEAH! WE'RE DOING IT!
WE'RE [bleep] DOING IT!
WOW.
YOU HAVE SUCH A SWEET FACE.
- AW, THANK YOU.
- ARE YOU, LIKE, MISSING
A CHROMOSOME OR SOMETHING?
- YEAH, FOR SURE.
FOR SURE.
BUT--BUT IT MAKES EVERYTHING
SO MUCH BETTER.
- I FEEL YOU.
I COULD SEE THAT.
I COULD TOTALLY SEE THAT.
- GOOD.
- I LOVE YOU GUYS.
AND LOOK AT YOU.
YOU STOLE A TABLECLOTH
FROM CHUCK E. CHEESE.
- HEY, MAN, IT'S A RECESSION.
IT'S A RECESSION.
- YOU TALKING ABOUT
YOUR TITS?
[laughs]
OH, MY GOD,
LOOK AT THAT.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU BOTH
MY SPACE NEEDLE.
BET YOUR [bleep]
SMELL LIKE PIKE'S PLACE.
TAKE A BOW, YOU GUYS.
YOU CAN GO BACK TO YOUR SEATS.
SUPER, SUPER COOL OF YOU LADIES
TO COME UP HERE.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR PUBIC HAIRS
COMING IN.
- ALL RIGHT, ANY TIME NOW.